Light mapping is a way of lighting objects to make them look highly realistic,
or for that matter highly stylized. For static objects in particular, those
that aren't moving, the idea is to pre-compute shadows, reflected light, and
any other lighting effects desired. For example, you can see in this scene that
the smaller cube has a subtle realistic shadow effect on the larger one. This
type of effect is difficult to compute at interactive rates. This is how the
process works. First, here's a scene without any lighting applied. Every
surface is assigned an additional texture called a light map. This extra
texture will be used to capture the light's effect. Some offline process is
done to the illumination in the scene. As much time as desired, can then be
spent determining how much light reaches each pixel on each surface. The
results are stored in the light map. The light map is a mosaic texture, holding
many different surfaces' illumination calculations. For example, the lower left
corner of this light map is for the ground plane. You can see the two shadows
of the cubes laying on it. When the objects are displayed, the fragment shader
takes the object's color texture and multiplies it by the corresponding light
map texture. This gives the surface an illuminated look. Here's the final
result. Note that it's the same or darker than the original image without
illumination. This is why light maps are sometimes half jokingly called dark
maps, since they lessen the overall light. In theory you could bake the
lighting into each color texture itself instead of using a separate light map
texture. While possible, this can quickly get expensive. One major advantage of
light maps is that they can have a much lower resolution than the texture on
the surface itself, and can be stored in a single color channel instead of
three. Rather than storing six high resolution textures per cube in this scene,
each with the lighting baked in, just one texture and six small light maps are
stored for each.